this could ruin the whole red carpet
experienced me everyone is Christian's
more here at the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter red carpet event I have a
box full of Bertie Botts jelly beans and
we're gonna have the talent who walks
the carpet use this wand to grab the
flavor beam between you and me they're
all really bad are you familiar with the
Bertie Botts jelly beans candy in the
films are you gonna make me guess their
names or something hello Neil family
they're basically jelly beans with not
so good flavors and some good flavors so
we have a collection of both so this is
like real ass isn't it with beans
basically oh yes we have a wand you're
just gonna stick it in there and you're
gonna pick one up here we go you think
it's booger of course okay yeah going
down going down
it looks citrusy but I know it's not
gonna be oh my go once I think that one
might be rot in a no letters with sugar
and hint of happiness magical it takes
like if I were to eat the latex Michael
Myers mask okay
it's booger bike and nice LCD thing yeah
it's not great it's not what it looks
like frog or something looks like frog
just kidding okay
I'm very trusting it looks like poo do
it oh it's a red one they don't like it
I don't think she likes the earthworm
flavor dirt
yes dingy you got dirt that's so
exciting how fun well that's that's
great
yeah love so Tom fell in love so good
enough all right thanks